hopefully help inflation for households
and the second thing is more people are
going to be paying more tax and if
they're doing that they're going to be
spending less those two things are going
to hopefully drive down inflation
slightly which means there's less
pressure on the bank of England to raise
rates
um they also have a bit more credibility
now there's a lot more around making the
right moves to kind of fun you know plug
this funding Gap and so it means that in
terms of the concern viewers have around
mortgage rates increasing hopefully
this should come off the table slightly
we could see a couple more raises but
not as far as we thought previously well
I think you've actually answered a
question number two which is from David
saying well anything encourage the bank
of England to keep interest rates as
they are so I think okay the other thing
I could say about that as well is you've
got we were talking about raising
interest rates and talking about
inflation but the other part of the
equation is about we've now we're now
falling into a recession so what we have
heard today is that you know that's
become official and what the bank of
England doesn't want to do is if they
keep raising interest rates then they
could stifle growth and they could
prolong a recession or the worst thing
is we could go into stagflation let me
explain it's an awful term it just means
that you've got high inflation but
you've also got high unemployment and so
the bank of England can't really do what
it can to try and solve it so actually
from what we heard today that should
really put a bit more of a limit on what
the bank of England does
um well a bit of good news potentially
for people worried about that interest
rate rise question three is about
pensioners Richard power has asked I'm a
pensioner what happens to me okay um
there are going to be three things three
ways that they're going to be impacted
first of all they get a 300 pound
payment next year
um which is available to pensioners to
help with energy costs and we saw that
last year so it's just a repeat of what
we saw last year the second thing is
that the state pension is set to rise by
over 10 to 10.1 percent
um which of course is good news
um but the third thing is that
um dividends the the personal allowance
the allowance the amount of dividends
that you could earn before you started
to be charged tax is going to be halved
and the reason that's important for
pensioners is some pensioners do earn
through their pension
um dividends and things like that could
really affect the amount of tax that
they pay and now question four is about
NG obviously something that so many
people are really concerned about this
winter here's Jane she asks will the
energy support payments continue for
every household not just those on
benefits and pensionless
I mean I think it's going to be such a
tough situation for so many families
because really the only thing that we
heard today to try and help people with
their energy bills just people in
general is the energy price guarantee
continuing and so what we're seeing here
is that for an average household it's an
average household it's not for everybody
but for an average household
um the price of energy should you know
has risen to about two and a half
thousand pounds and from April of next
year they're saying it'll be capped
ideally but around about three thousand
pounds
um but apart from that all these Energy
payments they're really much more
targeted at people who are on benefits
so at least there is going to be some
support extended but we might be having
to pay a bit more absolutely this year
and if we compare to what we were paying
uh in 2021 I mean we were paying back on
average 760 pounds for energy bills so
yes they're creeping up I mean it's
absolutely staggering so families are
already going to be struggling with the
hike right uh question five this is from
people on middle incomes because
obviously many values all fall into this
category this is Sarah she says I work
with a colleague who gets Universal
Credit support with housing and works
the minimum allowed hours she's taking
home more than me in Universal Credit
and wages what support will there be for
people like myself a middle wage earner
who feel that we're being missed and I
think she's absolutely right and I think
that people that are in that bracket are
absolutely being missed and we've seen
this at every budget whether it was a
self-employed the first time round when
we heard about furlough there are people
that when we say fall through the cracks
this is the majority of the population
but what's happened is a lot of the the
support that's coming out is being
targeted and what it means is that for
people that are just about managing and
just about surviving they're going to
feel all the pressure and not get enough
support so actually bad news and for
Sarah really not too much targeted at
you question six is about council tax
Charlie's got very simple very direct
question is council tax going up
I mean I think it is so what we heard in
the statement was
um councils used to be restricted they
only used to be able to increase council
tax by less than three percent or they
had to call a referendum and what we
heard today and it was very Sly but um
they are actually local authorities are
now been given the ability to raise
um council tax by the amount they need
to to cover their costs which means that
again if you're hearing the news
um it's likely that council tax is going
to exceed 2 000 pounds a year for a lot
for millions of families around the UK
and that really is going to impact an
awful lot of people it certainly is uh
students next question seven here's
Grace how will the statement affect
full-time University students I mean
it's a great question and obviously you
know lots come out today everybody needs
to kind of Wade through it nothing
specific like explicit came out but I
think what was interesting is
potentially for her is around the jobs
Market you know there was a lot of news
around investing in Innovation r d and
especially in nuclear renewable and we
do have to find a way to become a bit
more energy and independent so it's less
direct support or impact as a student
but potentially just being aware of the
type of jobs that are going to be on the
marketplace in future might be something
to be aware of yes well if you're a
university student that's what it's all
about right um You would hope anyway
right let's have a look at the next
question shall we this is a question
number eight and it's about benefits
Neil asks what does the Autumn statement
mean to disable people who are on
benefits so specifically for people that
are getting disability benefits and
obviously they have to meet that
criteria for it to be able to be paid as
easily as possible
um they're due a payment of 150 pounds
next year so that would be good news
yeah so that of course is the operating
benefits and learn with their inflation
it's a bit of good news therefore at
Neil right number nine question nine
another viewer has emailed in to say
what's going to happen to the tax rate
on taking dividends from my limited
company so quite a specific question it
is a specific question but it's going to
affect a lot of people because what a
lot of people tend to do is when they
start up a company they won't pay
themselves a salary they'll try and pay
themselves they'll wait to see how much
profit the company makes pay their staff
and pay themselves a dividend with
whatever you know is left over and it is
bad news so what we saw is you used to
be able to earn up to five thousand
pounds without paying tax on dividends
that got cut to two thousand pounds what
we heard today is that's going to be
slashed in half to one thousand pounds
next April and the April after that is
going to come down again by half so
actually really the majority of any
earnings by dividends is going to be
taxed that's a huge difference and isn't
it coming down from five thousand
absolutely
um yeah exactly and I think it's going
to put a lot of pressure on business
owners as well yeah so a bit of bad news
there for that particular uh viewer but
let's rattle on shall we to the next
question it's great to get through so
many uh it's really nice to sort of have
all these clear answers as well we
appreciate it
um very novel for someone who's used to
interviewing politicians the whole time
right question 10 uh Morris has this to
say my state pension is going to rise by
10.1 but that means my personal tax
allowance will reduce by the same amount
so my private pensions will attract more
tax so I'm worse off each month I
believe this is a form of stealth tax am
I correct and this is a really good
question because I think this is this is
the key issue if we talked about one
issue from the Autumn statement it's all
about Stealth taxes which really just to
explain it it's a way where new taxes
are introduced or in this case people
are paying more tax and they don't
realize it and what's happened is is
that you've got um for just everybody in
general the fact that they've Frozen the
personal allowance they Frozen
thresholds it means as the cost of
living is rising and people are paying
out more you might see your salary
increase which is great news but
actually you tend to be worse off
because it's not going to keep up with
the rising cost of living and now you're
in a different tax bracket so if we come
back to this question in particular
um that's exactly the point there is
that the state pension is going to rise
but because it's rising and it could put
people into other tax brackets they
could end up paying more tax and where
people get penalized the most is when
they just do that little jump you know
if you're if you're far up you know
above it or far below it you know it's a
little bit more gradual but people that
are jumping and changing tax brackets
that can really have a big effect so it
is something to I think watch out for
yeah so Morris has definitely spotted
something there when he's had a look at
the impact on himself another question
about pensions question 11 will
pensioners on pension credit get the 900
pound cost of living payment as well as
the 300 pounds to pensioner households I
mean I don't think so because the 900
pounds again what we heard today was is
going to be given to people that are on
Universal Credit and means tested
Universal Credit so it's really again if
they qualify for that then the answer
would be yes but in terms of a pensioner
specifically
um that was the 300 pound payment and
not the 900. okay thanks for clarifying
um right uh question 12 and this is
about the housing market lots of
questions I'm sure lots of concerned
about what's happening with the property
Market Bonnie says my partner and I are
really struggling to get on the property
ladder we both work full time but we
can't afford a mortgage the government
doing anything to help those that work
get on the property ladder
um what they've what they announced was
there's no change so there were some
cuts to stamp Duty that were announced
and they're going to be extended so in
that respect again it's I mean the
government you always talk about there's
a saving it's not a saving it's the fact
that there's not going to be an increase
you know whatever we heard is going to
be extended so a cut to stamp Duty
obviously then lowers the cost to be
able to get onto the property ladder but
in terms of initiatives we've heard
previously around you know special
payments or anything like that um we
haven't you know heard any announce any
announcements yet okay I'll guess the
only glimmer of hate for Bonnie is that
the obr are saying there's gonna be a
fall in house prices I mean I know some
people will see that as a big negative
but I guess for first-time buyers like
Bonnie not necessarily at bad
consequence of the problems with the
economy we're seeing uh Jack Davis let's
go to question 13 now he's saying as
someone who's on 25 000 pounds a year
how does this affect me am I going to be
paying more tax
well see the people that are going to be
paying more tax are the ones that are
going to be getting pay Rises so he's
actually not going to feel any effect
apart from the fact that obviously the
cost of living is continuing to rise but
in terms of numbers so you said 25 000
pounds so you've got a personal
allowance of 12 570 pounds that he won't
get charged any tax on and above that
he'll be charged 20 tax so he's not
going to see any differences but the
message today is if he's lucky enough to
be working for a you know a nice
employer that is going to be raising um
his salary that potentially he'll be
paying more tax as well there you go uh
thanks very much let's squeeze in one
more question shall we this is about the
high rate of tax question 14. one of our
viewers asking when will the 45 tax
threshold change down to 125 140 pounds
when is that going to come into effect
it's a great question a good easy answer
but I can just
um it's going to come in in April and so
what tends to happen when new measures
are brought out unless they specifically
say it's immediate which is very very
rare it usually comes in for the next
tax year and the next tax year starts on
the 6th of April next year so expect it
there and well what a pleasure to get so
many clear answers to questions on the
program and thanks to talking us through
uh so many things that we know that our
viewers are concerned about thank you
well we can return to Central Lobby now
and our political correspondent Ali
Fortescue is there Ali it feels like
we're all just digesting uh the Autumn
statement we've been getting lots of
takes from all sorts of different people
on the program so I'm interested to know
what stood out food to you from what
Jeremy Hunt had to say
well Sophie I I think what's going to be
fascinating is a response from Tory MPS
I was just outside the 1922 committee
not far from where I'm standing now as
Jeremy Hunt the chancellor went in to
meet his back benches we've seen in the
past just how powerful
um that benches can be and we've seen
the impact they've had on the last two
prime ministers
um and I have to say it wasn't
particularly packed house there were
plenty of people that I suppose have
gone back to their constituencies
already I was speaking to a couple of
MPS on their way in two Northern MPS and
both of them said look they're going to
wait to see
um to digest as you put it the Autumn
statement wait to see what all of this
means for their constituents I think
there were a couple of them that did
have concerns around things like fuel
Duty and the word growth comes up a lot
does this government have a plan for
growth will growth be stifled by tax
Rises and of course pendulum has swung
so fast since Liz truss's budget let's
talk to Anthony Mangal he's an